pass à mundir qui a fait énormément
réagir aussi mon mundir hier hier on
recevait ellisabeth Levy dont les propos
avaient fait beaucoup parler le matin et
ensuite c'est mundir qui a fait parler
donc c'est vrai que ça a été il a voulu
lire une lettre c'est la première fois
que j'entends quelqu'un lire une lettre
dans cette émission c'était c'était
magnifique fait riment l'a fait aussi je
vais l'appeler Renand lu une lettre dans
laquelle mon dire revient sur l'histoire
des musulmans en France et cette lettre
a fait énormément réagir on va parler
dans un instant avec Juliette Briance
qui est avec nous regardez si vous
n'avez pas vu mir hier ça ça a fait
beaucoup parler jque ce que vous avez
dit effectivement c'est à vomir nous
musulmans on s'excuse c'est vrai on
s'excuse d'avoir sauvé la France lors de
la deuxième guerre mondiale conquise en
3 jours nous sommes allés au front avec
des prières qui visiblement ne
dérangeaient personne à cette époque-là
pendant que la majorité des Français
collaborent bien à l'abri et qu'une
infine minorité de héros résistit
difficilement tant la délation svissait
en juillet 1944 nous musulmans madame
lesv on s'excuse car nous sommes allés
jusqu'à les accueillir et est protégé
dans notre pays d'origine pour finir
madame Lévy vous quiê éiste il y a a
quelqu'un qui s'appelle Albert Camu que
j'aime beaucoup et il dit que la bêtise
insiste toujours alors il faut laisser
parler voilà Juliette est avec nous
Juliette brance directeur de la
communication magazine l'incorrect
influenceuse patriote merci d'être là
vous avez pensé quoi de la lettre de
mundir hier
elle m'a beaucoup
choqué déjà j'ai trouvé le ton assez
désastreux c'est-à-dire que quand on
demande à une dame qui s'appelle Levy et
qui vient en plus de visionner 45
minutes image atroce sur les actes
terroristes du Hamas du 7 octobre si
dascho et la guestapo ça lui dit quelque
chose bah moi vous dire que c'est
légèrement sordide mais au-delà de ça et
du ton général
euh bah tout était faux quoi tout était
faux pratiquement ou en tout cas la
quasi totalité était faux alors les
musulmans ont sauvé la France mais je
suis désolé mais faut faut faut
dégonfler son melon quoi et à un moment
donné je ne sais pas où vous êtes allé à
l'école ou qui vous a appris ça mais il
faut dégonfler son melon les musulmans
n'ont jamais sauvé la France les
musulmans morts ça représente s les
musulmans ça représente 100000 morts sur
les deux guerres mondiales sur les deux
guerres mondiales donc ces gens sont
venus ils sont morts pour la France et
on on les remercie mais rien qu'à la
Première Guerre mondiale il y a eu
1300000 morts donc les musulmans n'ont
pas sauvé la France vous voyez ce que je
veux dire ensuite les musulmans ont
sauvé la France pendant que les Français
étaient chez eux tapis à collaborer mais
vous prenez pour qui mais vous crachez
mais mais sur les Français sur toutes
leur mémoire les la collaboration les
historiens l'estiment entre 2 à 5 % en
France Jean Moulin il est pas né à Raba
d'accord Charles de Gaulle pareil c'est
un français donc c'est pas les musulmans
qui ont sauvé la France c'est les
Français qui ont sauvé la France et les
Alliés je poursuis quand vous dites que
les Français ont réparé pareil les
Français pardon les musulmans ont réparé
la France pendant les tres glorieuses
mais pendant les 30 glorieuses au pic
les les les comment dire les les
étrangers dans le BTP il représentaient
30 % et parmi ces 30 % la majorité était
des Italiens et des Portugais et et des
Espagnols et les les maghrébains donc
les musulmans
représentai ne représentit en tout que 6
% de de de des des des gens dans le
BTP à l'époque des tromes glorieuses
donc c'est pareil qui est-ce qui vous a
appris que les musulmans ont reconstruit
la France alors que c'est faux et
dernière chose et après j'arrête quand
on parle d'histoire euh c'est bien vous
pouvez voir la préttenion de parler
d'histoire et vous avez par exemple vous
avez cité l'imam de la mosquée de Paris
qui effectivement euh aurait sauvé des
Juifs aurait abrité des Juifs mais faut
parler de tout à ce niveau-là à ce
compte là il faut parler de tout parce
que alors déjà on vous a jamais demandé
de vous excuser ça c'est la première
chose personne ne vous a jamais demandé
de vous excuser et puis vous avez été
très sélectif parce que vous avez jamais
parlé par exemple des 200000 musulmans
en uniforme allemand qu'on a censé en 43
vous n'avez jamais parlé des divisions
de SS entières composé de musulmans dans
les Balcans vous n'avez pas parlé du
mfti de Jérusalem qui avait des
relations très étroites avec avec Hitler
et qui a empêché des des milliers de
Juifs des pays de l'Est de s'exiler
enfin de fuir en Palestine pour pour
éviter les camps et vous avez pas dit
que dans tous les pays arabo-musulmans
en ce moment mcamp fa un Bestseller qui
se vend extrêmement bien bien bien en
plus c'est même pas comparable que dans
les pays occidentaux et vous n'avez vous
l'avez balayé d'un revers de main jamais
écoutter Élisabeth Levi quand elle vous
a dit que depuis 30 ans voire plus tous
les morts tous les morts juifs tués
parce qu'ils sont juifs l'ont été par la
main de musulmans mais je sais que c'est
dur à entendre mais c'est une simple
vérité Coulibali Mera tous nos attentats
myiam knol Sarah limi enfin on pourrait
en citer plein et vous pouvez pas m'en
citer un qui qui n'a pas à voir avec
avec l'islam mais donc voà et encore une
fois ellizabeth Lévy que vous avez
agressé sans raison n'avait jamais dit
que tous les musulmans étaient
antisémites elle a dit qu'il y avait un
problème de surreprésentation en ce
moment dans l'islam avec l'antisémitisme
et c'est tout voilà qu'est-ce que tu non
je trouve ça toujours très intéressant
d'être jugé par l'extrême droite l
d'acord merci si vous ça répondre je je
finis je finis mais tous les deux je
vous prends il y a aucun problème euh
alors moi je suis responsable de ce que
je dis je su mais je suis pas respons
attends tu dis quoi tous les deux c'est
qui
non tous les deux je vous prends il AEL
toi aussi je te prends donc pour le pour
le coup pour le coup moi je suis
responsable de ce que je dis mais je
suis pas responsable de ce que de ce que
les gens pensent donc je je parle en
connaissance de cause je parle d'une
certaine histoire qui a eu lieu
visiblement on n'est pas d'accord
là-dessus en tempant normal je me
mélange jamais avec avec l'extrême
droite je suis allé je vous connaissais
pas je suis allé voir effectivement ce
que vous faisiez je suis tombé sur sur
sur votre profil profil Twitter d'accord
et là je lis en plus vous likez vous
avez liké ça donc d'un de vos fans elle
a un plateau d'arabe en face d'elle des
islamistes car oui la majorité des
musulmans en France est islamiste c'est
une minorité qui ne l'est pas bon ça
c'est làdessus et ensuite il y en a un
autre qui dit
et vous avez massacré les nôtres lors
des attentats et vous massacrez les
nôres chaque jour pour revenir à ce que
vous me
disiez je viens vous faire une DI vous
allez répondre à rien je su juste d'trme
drite attendez vous me dites que j'ai
agressé madame
l est- que je peux
finiréz je je réponds à ce qu' dit je
suis en train de dire que vous me dites
que vous avez que j'ai agressé madame l
je nsument pas agresser madame Lévi j'ai
répondu justement à une attaque qu'elle
dit en disant qu'elle stigmatise les
musulmans qui sont tous antisémit elle a
pas dit
ça seu elle a pas dit ça une seule fois
elle a dit que la majorité la majorité
des elle a dit que la majorité des fois
où les Juifs se sentaient en dangé ça
prenait d'AC qui venait de gens
musulmans et après elle a dit trois fois
pendant le plateau que elle répétait
encore une fois que tout les musulmans
n'étaient pas antisémites et loin de là
c'était une minor Mad elle dit elle l'
dit d'accord mais en tout cas pas
d'accord mais c'est juste dire c'est
factuelz répondu mes arguments que je
viens de vous exposer ce soir vous
m'avez juste répondu que j'étais
d'extrême droite et vous m'avez sorti
des tweets de Random là que
personne c'est moi qui écr ça c'est moi
quiz sur le reste ça prouve que il y a
des Algériens des indigènes qui sont
venus oui c'est par que vous avez dit
vous avez dit les musulmans ont sauvé la
France pendant que les Français
collaboraient c'est ça que vous avez dit
je je non je je nai non madame je n'ai
pas à cracher seulement ça c'est votre
interprétation ce n'est pas la mienne je
suis en train de vous dire qu'il y a
effectivement des indigènes musulmans
qui ont au péril de leur vie SAU la FR
ça jamais pas une sele fois pas une
seule fois laisse Mund reparler non
parce que j voulait parler M qu'est-ce
que tu voulazis dire je dis tout
simplement que ceux qui rêvent qu'il y a
une opposition entre les Juifs de France
et les musulmans de France ben c'est à
eux de quitter la France tout simplement
pardon quoi c'est au français de quitter
la France non je suis en train de dire
ceux qui rêvent ceux qui rêvent que les
Juifs et les musulmans s'entretuent B
c'est eux qui n'aiment pas la France
tout simplement c'est pas la France que
je mais qui mais qui rêve de ça mais V à
côté de la absol pas je suis absolument
pas côté de la répond à mais je réponds
que il me répond à rien donc je ne sais
pas quoi répondre qu'est-ce que voulez
répondre vous avez répondu à rien j'ai
jamais dit que je voulais que les juifs
et les musulmans s'entretu j'ai jamais
dit qu' avait pas de tir avait pas de
combattant musulmans je les ai même cité
j'ai dit qu'il en avait 100000 mais ce
n'était donc pas la majorité loin de Mor
bah si vous avez dit les musulmans on
sauv la France mais alors pasment qu
Jeant pas
AG pas AG sur un ton courto je n'
absolument pas
dis j'ai pas l je vous parce que moi
parle lesamp concentration ça me parle
mais je n'ai pas dit et tout
ça
chose vous êes F de vous mieux juste
vous comprenez les réactions qu' a eu
parce qu'il y a eu des réactions il des
bonnes réactions il des mauvaises
réactions sur la sur ce qui s'est passé
hier sur la phrase de elabeth Lev non
non de de ce qui s'est passé hier bah
oui moi je comprends que j'ai été outré
donc
je je vous aviez tweé làdus mais
vraiment j'étais mal à l'aise j'étais
mal à l'aise parce qu'en plus elle est
venue je trouve dans une démarche très
honnête et sincère où elle voulait
vraiment faire part d'un mal-être et
c'est le malêtre de la communauté juive
en ce moment et son malêtre il est il
est justifié ou pas alors ça vous ça je
vous laisse l'apprécier moi je pense que
je pense que oui elle venait de
visionner mais 45 minutes d'horreur elle
avait encore la la main qui tremblait ça
se voyait et elle s'est fait mais traité
de tous les noms sur ce plateau de
raciste d'islamophobe et cetera parce
qu'elletait une inquiétude une
inquiétude qui est d'ailleurs beaucoup
partagé par les Juifs qui qui qui
s'exodent par exemple vous avez jamais
dit non plus que au 20e siècle il y a eu
un exode de 800000 Juifs de tous les
pays musulmans qui sont partis j'ai
parlé 2 minutes madame donc j'ai parlé
de minut vous avez écrit une lettre
vousez pu mais justement donc je l'ai
dit donc voilà mais pas du tout attendez
laissez-moi finir donc moi j'ai 2
minutes donc j'ai dis ce que j'avais à
dire estce que j'ai dit était sincère
vrai tout simplement à partir du moment
où effectivement il se passe des choses
en France quoi tu rigoles frère c'est
lui mon sort
j'ai fait quoi tu sors j'ai rien fait
sors oui allez vas-y n on dire non
laisse tombé non non mais vas-y vas-y
c'est bon
bon vous vous sentez mal aussi pas du
tout
bien je rassure tout je suis très très
bien suis très très bien j'assume ce que
j'ai dit j'assume ce que je dis
totalement que je dis en j'ai répondu de
ce que
je de répondre plusard tu dis
répondassume ce que je
dis ce que j'assume pas madame je vous
répondre par par faire plaisir ce que
j'assume pas Madame c'est que vous êtes
train de dire que j'ai
invictimisé madame madame Ly alors que
j'ait cour en fait vous savez en parlant
de victime il y a 1100 actes antisémites
depuis le 7 octobre et on a l'impression
ou il a ouais y a 1500 actes antisémite
depuis le 7 octobre et si on vous écoute
on a l'impression que les victimes c'est
les musulmans vous trouvez pas ça un B
mais vous trouvez pas ça un peu biz hier
hier vous n avez fait à 1000 les enfin
c'était des larmes à 1 larmes vous étiez
là en train de nous expliquer comment
musul héros et VI j si je peux me
permettre de de de de de parler pour
Bund mir en fait ce qui ce qui voulait
dire je pense hier et ce qu'il veut dire
aujourd'hui c'est que lui il veut pas
que le comme l'a dit Gérard Darmanin que
le le conflit
euh s'exporte ici et que lui il a pas
envie que ce soit la guerre entre les
musulmans les Juifs entre ses potes
entre sa famille puisquil a de la
famille c'est ce que c'est ce qu' a
voulu dire mir je pense que c'est ça qu'
voulait dire c'est pour ça que je dis je
dis ceux qui veulent oppos c'est ça que
je voulais dire ce qui veulent opposer
les Juifs de France et les musulmans de
France madame
pardz passe actuellement ce qui se passe
actuellement on veut opposer de
communautés qui s'entendent très très
bien si
Madame
pasinentend très très bien faut voyager
un petit peu
vous PAL en Israël pas très bien pouro
par a des musul ça fait que du mal de ne
pas nommer les choses arrêtez de dire
qu'il son très bien ça pas vous étiez
mais moi moi ici j'ai dénoncé j'ai
dénoncé et je fais du terin la moindre
des choses je ve pas vous dire bravo
c'est la MO des chos je suis pas en
train de vous dire bravo bon ben alors
mais arrêtez de me dire qu'il y a aucun
problème entre les Juifs et les
musulmans en ce moment enfin enfin ça
relève vraiment il y a il y a un grave
problème à Gaza et en Israël et non pas
du tout donc les 1500 actes depuis
le je suis pas
létimité se CP mais maintenant
l'ensemble des Juifs français et
l'ensemble des musulmans des musulmans
français s'entendent très très bien dire
sur la phrase d'hier tu te sens pas mal
à l'aise sur laquelle le fait de dire à
Elizabeth
léi de demander à à quelqu'un s'il
connaî
guestapo juste cette phrase là est-ce
que c'est quelque chose qui alors je te
réponds que tu me fais le même coup
qu'avec l'imam lorsque je dis à Isabelle
Lévi madame lisabeth pardon éisabeth
Lévi lorsque je lui dis est-ce que Daso
ça vous parle c'est parce que ça me
parle parle d'accord
voilàoup parle mais là effectivement toi
tu viens tu viens de haer tu viens tu
viens de hausser la tête ça prouve que
finalement tu me crois pas mais je suis
en train de dire quand je parle de Daso
ça me parle et les C de la mort ça me
parle je dis pas que ça te parle pas non
mais moi cétait quand je est-ce
ça c'est pas très de dire
ça j'urais pu dire ça me parle est-ce
que ça vous parle comme moi ça me parle
c'est peutêtre ça arrangé c'est ça le
dire comme ça n' rien à voir donc c'est
ça comme ça je souffle un peu depuis
tout à l'heure pourquoi alors j'ai juste
soufflé parce que je me suis dit mince
il part très très
mal l'accuser tout de suite d'extrême
droite avec ce qu'elle a dit avec
beaucoup de vérité j'ai voilà c'est pour
ça donc si tu l'as mal pris
excuse-m en revanche je trouve que tu as
été prêt je crois ta sincérité je crois
en ta sincérité il y a pas de problème
je pense que hier ce que tu as fait
c'est exactement ce que tu reprochais à
Elizabeth Lévi qui pose un vrai problème
problème ça se discute mais elle pose un
vrai problème en disant que il y a un
problème d'antisémitisme avec les
musulmans il y a pas que les néonazis de
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
Jean-Marie Le Pen qui pose un problème
en ce moment d'antisémitisme c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut mettre sur la
table elle a choqué hier mais c'était
bien qu'elle choque et et toi tu lui
disais qu'elle elle globalisait et que
tous les musulmans étaient antisémites
tu et là tu fais exactement pareil dans
ta lettre tu as fait exactement pareil
nous musulmans on a sauvé la France
pendant que la majorité des Français
collaborent tu fais exactement la même
chose justement j'ai été à l'inverse
j'ai été à l'inverse quand je dis nous
musulmans on s'excuse c'est justement
pour dire que tous les musulmans en
France ne sont pas antisémit et la
France n'est pas tombée en 3 jours la
France n'est pas tombée en 3 jours ni en
qu d'accord mais vous avez dit la France
est tombée en 3 jours
d'accordis le blis c'est juste
uneoui c'est une guerre rapide la France
n'est pas tombé en 3 jours pe importe
d'accord la drôle de guerre elle a duré
8 mois enfin voilà donc non mais en fait
vous
a
littéralement rien à renir de vrai dans
tout ce que vous avez dit de toute votre
diat pourtant vous l'aviez écrite vous
l'aviez écrite voyz moi j'ai même pas de
note il y a un élément qui est vrai
c'est que la la la Grande Mosquée de
Paris a sauvé 1732
ju32 juif 1732 Juifs pendant ans
d'ailleurs je suis pas en train
d'essayer de minimiser les bonnes
actions des musulmans qui sont morts
pour la France ou qui se sont se sont
battus avec vérité pour la France mais
c'est pas du tout mon mon projet par
contre vous par contre vous vous avez
effacé tout ce qu'on
fait
rés quit la
FR sur les PL commémtiv dans les
villages a pas écrit M fois
vraiment musul sauvé la France moi je
vois je vois pas beaucoup de
mundir redescendons il s'agit pas encore
une fois de minimiser les actes h musul
qui sont mors pour la
France vot histoire votre histoire
c'estire franement voil cétait AB je dis
cétait et ça vraiment ça a choqué tout
le monde et
[Musique]
moi Mme
dire non mais je suis un
peu je suis un peu dégoûté par Madame
mais respectuusement comprend un cours
d'histoire de votre part euh qui euh
émane effectivement d'une partie de
l'extrême droite qui est extrêmement
vindicatif contre les musulmans et
d'autre part la seule erreur de mundir
ce sont les chiffres que vous avez
repris d'accord mais là vous êtes en
train de faire ce que fait madame non
mais vous êtes en train de faire ce que
fait madame Lévy c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
vous minorez totalement le rôle des
musulmans pendant la guerre vous êtes en
train d'effacer vous l'histoire des
musulmans très bien que derrière
l'abiléè j'ai même pas dit un mot
derrière l'habileté de votre rétorique
il a les 100000 musulmans on les efface
les Marocains qui ont libéré la Corse en
1943 on s'en fout vous êtes en train de
balayer l'apport et l'impact des
musulmans en France au nom de vos
croyances et ça c'est dégueulasse que
vous faites à mir c'est
dégueulasse RP je l'ai répété au moins
trois fois il ne s'agit absolument pas
de minor les actes héroïques de tous ces
musulmans qui sont morts pour la France
répé répé TR fois et là vous me dites
vous minorez ok bon alors en faitien à
vous dire Monsieur si vous
pastrmeite j'ai juste dit ma vérité et
une vérité en fait factuelle parce que
contrairement à Monsieur je connais mon
histoire et puis c'est tout quoi ENF
j'ai rien dit d'extrème droite- que vous
AZ lui dire à part ça par tout est fa
dans ce qu'elle dit c elle manipule tout
elle prend tr
chiffr elle va dire bientôt elle a
minimisé totalement le rôle des alliés
pendant la libération c'estàd que pour
vous ce sont les Français qui sont
révoltés contre l'allem vous avez cité
les chiffres des collaborationnistes
100000 on est d'accord entre 2 et 5 %
mais ce sont les alliés qui nous ont
sauvé c'est mais vous savez très bien
vous réécrivez l'histoire à l'OND de vos
croyan musul sa non plus c'est pas plus
les musulmans que les non musulmans mais
c'est pas moins les musul te trompe sur
un point c'est que c'est les réseaux
catholiques qui étaient les plus
puissants en matière de de résistance et
qui ont organiser une partie de la
résistance les communistes évidemment
mais les réseau le réseau catholique via
les diocèses via via tout le tout tout
tout le tout ce qui était en place les
écoles les religieux et cetera bien plus
que d'autres
confessions pour finir non mais pour
finir voilà moi je je suis venu dire ma
vérité défendre ellisabeth Levi aussi
parce que vraiment j'ai été touchée j'ai
été touché par le le traitement qu'elle
a reçu ici j'ai trouvé que j'ai trouvé
totalement injuste et voilà et donc pour
terminer pour termin
personnetais personne qui lui manqué de
respect alors nous alors alors je va
vous dire s'il vous plaît s'il plît s'il
plaît nous nous quand on est on était
sur le plateau l' pas à priori qui éé ce
qui a été ressenti c'est qu'il y avait
une meute contre elle contre éisabeth l
é ceux qui ét contre elle qui ont parlé
exactement c'est ça parce que ellisabeth
elle est tellement mine de rien est
tellement forte que j' me dit voilà
s'est pris islamophobe et raciste dans
la tête quand
même il y a eu l'impression qu'il y
avait que des gens qui étaient contre
Elisabeth Levi mais comme j'ai fait
parler que ceux qui étaient contre
Elisabeth Levi parce que forcément
Elisabeth Levi elle défendre tout
seulément ça a donné l'impression d'un
plateau hostile contre elle voilà mais
voir c'est mundir et Gill qui ont parlé
ensemble mais quand vous avez voilà
c'est Gill verd il est contre tout le
monde non c'est pas ça c mais juste ah
je voulais juste dire on pourrait rendre
hommage à tous les Marocains les
tirailleurs sénégalais les Algériens ont
contribué à sauver la FR répond à ça
arrêtez tout le temps c'est bon ce qu'
vient de dire on fait tout le temps
c'est
bon merci à tous allez tout
suite